hemos hablado mucho sobre lentes
convexos por lo que de un vídeo rápido
sobre lentes cóncavos ya que no hay
muchas combinaciones que hacer con este
tipo de lentes entonces vamos a hablar
sobre lentes contamos y recuerden que
esta palabra cóncavo bueno en lo
particular esta parte de cabo me
recuerda a acabar como si tomar una pala
e hiciera un hoyo que deja un hueco
parecido a esto por eso me acuerdo que
los cóncavos tienen esta forma así que
vamos a dibujar un lente cóncavo que va
a tener las caras con cabas en ambos
lados
quizás quedó un poquito exagerado hasta
que estoy dibujando pero bueno es para
acceder en una idea iba a ser simétrico
además de dibujar el lente voy a indicar
aquí cuál es el eje principal su eje de
simetría y además voy a poner los puntos
focales de cada uno de estos lados
este es un foco y este es otro foco
ahora vamos a imaginar que tenemos un
objeto que se encuentra un poco más
lejos que este punto focal aquí estoy
señalando la posición de mi objeto con
la flecha y vamos a tomar un punto de
este objeto que va a emitir un rayo de
luz paralelo al eje principal bueno en
este caso con los lentes contamos lo que
va a pasar es que la luz se va a
retractar de manera que si es un rayo
paralelo el que entre aquí el rayo al
salir del lente va a dar la impresión de
que viene de la dirección del punto
focal entonces si yo
señaló más o menos cuál es la dirección
del punto focal el rayo retractado va a
salir más o menos así en esta dirección
ahora voy a tomar otro radio que también
sale de este punto pero aquí no voy a
hacer que pase por el punto focal como
hemos visto en todos los vídeos
anteriores lo que va a pasar aquí es que
este radio va a salir de este punto iba
a pasar justo por el medio del lente de
manera que no se va a retractar iba a
pasar directamente así para una persona
que esté observando estos rayos de luz
de este otro lado que va a pasar como
los va a ver esta persona vamos a
dibujar les de su
su ojo medio extraño
de su frente su nariz
su boca
más o menos ese es el perfil que va a
ver esta persona bueno para el cerebro
de esta persona al ver estos rayos le va
a dar la impresión de que ambos rayos de
luz vienen de una fuente en común este
rayo de luz le va a dar la impresión de
que vamos a ponerle otro color de que
viene
en esta dirección
y este otro rayo de luz pues le va a dar
la impresión de que ven acá por lo que
la imagen virtual que va a ver esta
persona va a ser esta de acá va a ser
una imagen más pequeña no es tan
invertida y más cercana que la imagen
del objeto original
y eso es toda esa idea general sobre los
lentes cóncavos